sinhozinho simpático da foto foi um
biólogo escocês chamado alexander
fleming
um belo dia ele saiu de férias quando
ele voltou
ele percebeu que ele tinha esquecido de
jogar fora as culturas de bactéria que
ele estava trabalhando no laboratório
enfim estragou todas as culturas estavam
mofadas enquanto ele descartava aquelas
culturas placas de petri
ele conversava com um colega dele
laboratório
ele observou que em algumas dessas
plaquinhas em algumas dessas culturas de
bactérias onde crescia o mofo aquele
fungo tinha uma aura e não crescia
bactéria e achou aquilo muito curioso e
resolveu estudar aquilo então descobriu
que esse fundo onde não crescia bactéria
ao redor era uma cepa rara de penicilina
notato e que subprodutos desse fungo a
penicilina o suquinho do fungo ele
consegue matar bactérias e continua
estudando aquilo desenvolveu um método
para separar a penicilina do pênis íleo
do fungo e começou a estudar as
propriedades daquela substância
descobriu que a penicilina matava só as
células bacterianas ela matava as
células do nosso corpo e foi assim
surgiu o primeiro antibiótico do mundo a
penicilina bobagem né
besteira pois é só que a penicilina
rendeu a descoberta da penicilina rendeu
o prêmio nobel de medicina ao fleming e
merecidamente porque a penicilina salvou
milhões de pessoas durante a segunda
guerra vem salvando milhões de pessoas
até hoje e só descoberta da penicilina
foi responsável pelo aumento de 10 anos
na expectativa de vida média humana ou
seja o ser humano passou a viver dez
anos a mais só por causa da descoberta
da penicilina porque até então as
pessoas morriam de dor de garganta de
inflamação na garganta de diarreia mas
no mundo morrem de diarreia cara que
louco
o que alexander fleming fez foi renovar
inovou a medicina pra sempre o que é
inovação é uma palavra que está um
pouquinho na moda principalmente para
quem trabalha com o startup quem
trabalha com tecnologia
eu vejo que as pessoas tenham a noção um
pouco errada do que é inovação porque as
pessoas tendem a pensar em inovação tem
que ser uma idéia que ela é feita do
zero ou então inovação tem que ser a uma
idéia super complexo com a teoria da
relatividade de einstein negócio assim e
não como o flamengo por exemplo observou
um mofo que ele estava pesquisando
aquilo que descobriu a penicilina
processo inovativo muitas vezes acontece
sem a gente nem perceber é simplesmente
se a gente olhar pela pela etimologia da
palavra à inovação nada mais é do que
você olhar pra dentro de algo que já
existe um conceito que já existe só que
é visto como desimportante e você olhar
com a nova ótica criar uma ideia ea
partir daí colocar a sua ideia em ação
eu queria compartilhar com vocês a
historinha minha pessoal envolve
inovação eu tive a honra de trabalhar
como pesquisador no laboratório que é o
sonho de consumo de todo nerd é o
paraíso do nerd herculândia a fusão da
escola de medicina de harvard com o
haiti
o intuito desse laboratório desenvolver
novas tecnologias para a área médica e
lau estudava as propriedades médicas de
cumprimentos específicos de ondas
eletromagnéticas um espectro visível em
bom português
eu trabalhava com as propriedades de
cura da luz luz
a gente conseguiu efeitos incríveis cara
como por exemplo e radical infecção
bacteriana de uma bactéria
multirresistente chamadas superbactérias
sem uso de antibiótico usando só luz
inclusive pra esse dex vocês vão ter a
honra de ver em primeira mão um esquema
computadorizado de última geração que eu
preparei para exemplificar e mostrar
claramente os resultados que a gente
conseguiu um laboratório
em só 62 minutos a gente conseguiu
erradicar a infecção que os antibióticos
mais potentes não conseguiram erradicar
mas tem um problema à luz sozinha ela
não consegue penetrar muito fundo no
tecido
então a gente conseguir tratar infecções
superficiais mas sim sim pq não fosse um
pouquinho mais profunda aos não ia
conseguir chegar a até aquela região
precisava de tratamento
então tive uma super idéia super
brilhante e pensei por que não construir
um conjunto de micro agulhas óticas onde
em cima de cada micro agulha a gente
coloca a micromet que vai focar o
experimento da agulha essa agulha vai
guiar luz pra dentro do tecido e assim a
gente consegue atingir uma área muito
maior
fiz um esquema computadorizado também
não deu pra ver que eu adoro fazer esse
negócio e foi mostrar que o pessoal do
laboratório achando que estava arrasando
com a minha ideia
cheguei pra ele só eu tive essa idéia a
gente faz esse conjunto de micro agulhas
ea idéia é meio que como se tivesse um
monte de sabre de luz de star wars do
tecido e eles vão entregar o spray de
tecido e tal
e eles com todo o tato do mundo pra nome
desmotivados eram caio a ideia legal
na verdade é tão legal que a gente até
pensou sobre isso
o problema é que o material que vai usar
qual é o método de produção que você vai
usar para confeccionar essas agulhas
isso tudo é um problema então a gente
teve uma descartando essa idéia daquela
brochado néné tá tudo bem pra casa
aí me debrucei em cima do problema
afinal de contas eles tinham dito que a
idéia legal ele já tinha pensado sobre
isso
então comecei a pesquisar materiais e
descobrir o ácido polilático é um
polímero é um termoplástico ele é
biodegradável biocompatível e meio
transparente parece um vidrinho quando
está em temperatura ambiente então ele
consegue guiar bem a luz adquirir esse
material comecei a brincar com ele no
laboratório primeira coisa que eu fiz
foi de reter ele pra achar o ponto de
fusão mais ou menos 137 graus celsius e
vi que ele parecia um caramelo quando
estava
mas tudo bem né porque cara quando tem
cabeça de gordon e comido tudo então tá
legal interessante parecer com o caramel
então a minha primeira ideia foi da
óbvia por construir moldes uma
impressora laser 3d porque eu tenho
acesso a todo aquele maquinário
maravilhoso de harvard noite e vou
derreter o material colocado dentro do
molde e vovô ter as minhas micro agulhas
mas o material era muito viscoso meio
como um caramelo derretido e ele não
escorre para dentro do molde
eu pensei eu posso tirar então o ar de
dentro destes moldes indo pro câmara
wako então vou tentar repetir isso em
uma câmera vácuo
nada feito material ainda é muito
viscoso e mesmo sem ar nenhum dentro dos
moldes
eu não consegui fazer com o material
escorresse pra dentro dos buracos do
molde
então coloquei uma pressão negativa
dentro do molde uma pressão positiva
fora do molde para empurrar aquele
material mesmo lá pra dentro
nada feito mas afinal de contas essa
escolha óbvia não fazer um molde de
reter o negócio colocar lá dentro
pensei caio você tá em harvard neymar
desenvolvendo pesquisa científica com um
monte de gente top da galáxia que você
não pensa em alguma coisa mais
científica mais complexa mais nerd
então eu pensei eu posso usar o decoro
metano que é um solvente transparente e
quando eu desenvolver o ácido polilático
de clorometano votar um líquido e esse
líquido vai entrar mais fácil dentro do
micro buraquinhos do do molde
então resolvi o material declarou metano
virou realmente um líquido transparente
me dera coloquei no molde e deu certo
consegui preencher os buracos uma ideia
quando o declaro metano evaporar se eu
tivesse ali é só o ácido polilático nos
formar no formato que eu queria
o resultado foi esse acho que não
preciso dizer mais nada né ou a meleca é
eu perdi as propriedades óticas porque o
negócio ficou branco completamente opaco
e as agulhas ficaram quebradiças elas
não iam conseguir penetrar no tecido
nunca e começou a bater um desespero
porque até aí já tinham se passado
algumas semanas na verdade alguns meses
eu não tinha nada para mostrar não tinha
nenhum resultado pra mostrar pra galera
só uma série de fracassos
vou continuar brincando com material e
testando várias propriedades dele e é se
essa é a idéia do pirulito de caramelo
para o negócio parecia um caramelo não
saía da minha cabeça e eu pensava que só
que eu tenho espírito de gordo mas eu
lembrei que lá em recife tem os
vendedores de pirulito de caramelo
ambulantes que eles vendem um pirulito
de metro que ele o cara ela puxa puxa
então eles derretem e quando eles puxam
vem pepino fitch controle tão assim eles
vêm de pirulito de um metro um metro e
meio uma coisa louca eu pensei caramba
esses caras fazem em pirulitos gigantes
que parece uma super agulha que não
posso usar esse método para fazer uma
micro agulha
afinal de contas ele a puxa puxa eu
posso spoiler eu posso eu possa derreter
esse material numa chapa e eu prestei
ela para 37 graus celsius colocar o
material a gente tivesse derretido eu ia
pensar ele com uma pinça cirúrgica e foi
o que eu fiz e realmente veio aqui fiap
com a base mais grossa à medida que ia
puxando ele afirmando estar amba
conseguir fazer uma micro agulhas
só que eu soltei o material estava
detido desmorou não tem problema tenha
uma bacia de água gelada coloquei meu
avô repetir o processo coloquei debaixo
da água gelada quando eu tirei lá estava
em riste o primeiro protótipo de
microagulha ótica do mundo feito baseado
no pirulito de caramelo
mostrei pro pessoal do laboratório e
ficaram estacionados é um cara que legal
não foi você conseguir fazer isso
renato a cidade provavelmente não tem
vendedor espírito de caramelo
então eu não te culpo por não saber né
desenvolver esse processo é complexo mas
um dia de contas não tardou conseguir
aperfeiçoar o método e desenvolver um
conjunto de micro agulhas óticas
só nos primeiros protótipos a gente
conseguiu aumentar em 300 por cento a
entrega de luz dentro do tecido e isso
gerou uma nova ótica cara isso fez com
que a gente visse aquela pesquisa sobre
um novo olhar porque até então era só um
estudo da luz mas nada muito complicado
ea partir do momento que eu mostrei que
a gente conseguiria entregar essa luz
eu disse galera isso aqui pode realmente
virar um tratamento de saúde e mudou
completamente a visão que todo mundo
tinha sobre a pesquisa a gente
desenvolveu novas novas coisas em cima
em cima desse trabalho
isso me rendeu o prêmio eu ganhei um
prémio árvore de uma equipe com o shorty
award um prêmio dado pela comunidade
acadêmica de harvard e mit e do ambiente
que tipo hospital das clínicas de
harvard por causa de uma idéia que eu
tive baseado em um pirulito de caramelo
é muito louco eu voltei para o brasil
trouxe a pesquisa comigo em parceria com
o laboratório
só que hoje a gente trabalha com a coisa
um pouquinho diferente de simplesmente
infecção bacteriana a gente trabalha com
uma condição chamada pé diabético que a
maior causa de amputações do mundo hoje
a gente continua desenvolvendo métodos
de entrega essa luz
a gente continua desenvolvendo
equipamentos capazes de entregar essa
luz e por causa de todo esse trabalho eu
fui parar na lista da forbes o que é uma
coroa com um negócio muito louco né
porque a lista da forbes geralmente eles
listam os bilionários então eu sou liso
e tô na lista da forbes
mas optou então fim vou ficar
perguntando muito porque mas eu tô na
lista da forbes como uma das
personalidades jovens mais promissores
do brasil
e eles me chamaram de inventor não foi
de empreendedor não foi de cientista não
foi de pesquisador não foi do estudante
e inventor que é um inventor senão um
inovador
não é verdade que eu sinceramente não
acho que eu inventei nada eu usei as
minhas experiências para construir uma
coisa nova a coisa diferente mas eu usei
coisas que já estavam ali que já
existiam que qualquer um podia ter feito
também
essa história de um inventor de inventar
de criar
acho que o ser humano ele não é muito
bom em criar de verdade coisas do zero o
ser humano é muito bom em recife
unificar as coisas que já existem
se eu pedir por exemplo pra você pensar
agora em uma curta você nunca viu na sua
vida normalmente não vai conseguir
pensar nessa cor
eu pedi pra você pensar um som com que
você nunca ouviu na sua vida você não
vai conseguir pensar nesse som mas eu
pedi pra você pensa em um ovo azul
escuro mesmo você nunca tendo visto a
galinha chocar um ovo azul você consegue
conceber essa idéia você consegue pensar
nisso pode até pensar num novo amarelo
ovo rosa não sei mas com elementos que
já existem que já estavam ali e que a
gente já conhece beethoven quando compôs
a nona sinfonia nos mesmos 12 notas
musicais que todos os músicos sempre
tiveram acesso ele inventou nota musical
nova mas ele usou as experiências dele
ele usou a alma dele para ressignificar
uma coisa que já existia
ele te olhar dele para aquilo e ele
inovou a música ele mudou a música para
sempre
picasso usou quem sabe o mesmo pincel e
tinta óleo da lojinha dos seus é que
outro artista podia ter comprado também
que a gente já usou nas aulas de artes
da gente do colégio também mas picasso
deu um olhar dele
as experiências dele de vida olhar dele
do mundo e colocou ele na zara esse
olhar nas artes
ele revolucionou as artes plásticas pra
sempre
a inovação não é um negócio que acontece
sozinho assim acordei inovador hoje é
uma inovação ela depende de outras
coisas para acontecer
a inovação depende da observação porque
você precisa ter experiências de vida né
você precisa ter vivenciar as coisas pra
conseguir inovar
você precisa olhar essas duas
experiências com criatividade é porque
você precisa dar um novo olhar aquelas
experiências que você já tem pra que daí
surge uma nova ideia mas o mais
importante de tudo você tem que colocar
essa tua ideia em prática porque uma
ideia sozinha ela não vale nada mas uma
ideia que aposta em prática essa muda o
mundo
obrigado à noite